hedge funds are talked a lot about in
the press and usually with a slightly
suspicious or negative tone so what I
want to do in this video is think about
or give us a way of thinking about
whether a hedge fund or really any
financial type of organization or
institution is good or bad and I won't
try to take one side or the other just
give you some type of things to think
about so the first thing that sometimes
is complained about when people talk
about hedge funds is that the
compensation structure because the hedge
fund gets 20% of the profits but if the
funds were to kind of blow up and go to
zero the hedge fund manager isn't on the
line for 20% of the losses people would
argue that that encourages hedge fund
managers to take disproportionate
disproportionate levels of risk and that
is true to some degree but one thing
that is true about hedge funds is that
usually it's expected that the the
manager or the general partner has some
of some of their own skin in the game so
in the example that I drew of Pete
Capital Fund one the manager committed
10 percent of the funds and what's more
important as opposed to just the
percentage of the total fund is what
percentage of Pete's total net worth is
in the fund some fund managers will put
a significant amount of their own
personal net worth in the fund so even
though they get 20 percent of the upside
if the fund would really do horribly if
it were to blow up that manager usually
will really be on the line and that's
really the job of the limited partners
here we've mentioned before that versus
a mutual fund the limited partners of a
hedge fund need to be sophisticated they
need to be accredited investors they
need to have a certain net worth they
need to show that they understand these
type of instruments and so it's really
the job of the limited partners and it's
really in their interest to make sure
that they're investing in a fund where
one Pete looks like a credible guy Pete
has some skin in the game and hopefully
a substantial amount of skin in the game
relative to Pete's net worth Pete has a
reputation and then they have to decide
their own comfort level with how
transparent Pete is a lot of hedge funds
won't tell their investors a lot of what
they're doing with this hundred million
sometimes they'll give a little bit more
information a little bit
that could be a negative obviously
because who knows maybe they're going to
Las Vegas and they're gambling away this
money but that's where the reputation of
the manager matters a lot but also the
secrecy actually could be good for the
limited partners because sometimes if
everyone knows exactly what's happening
inside of the fund and that information
goes out there could be other people
that could somehow trade against the
fund or make the same investments of the
fund or if this is a large fund go ahead
of that fund and try to buy whatever
this fund was trying to buy ahead of
time so there's there's kind of pros and
cons to the secrecy but that risk that
risk is definitely there and you know
one thing that I guess is probably
interesting to point out is that this
idea of getting a percentage of the
upside but not but having very limited
downside is not unique to hedge funds in
fact this is probably true of most
corporate executives in fact most
corporate of executives probably don't
have as much skin in the game you've all
heard about golden parachutes and all of
the rest with if if CEOs do really well
they usually get huge huge huge bonuses
if they do horribly and they get fired
they still get golden parachutes and
that actually probably doesn't happen to
hedge fund managers so this idea of a
percentage of the upside without the
same percentage of the downside isn't
unique to hedge fund managers it happens
to corporate executives it happens to
heads of banks it happens to bankers
generally where they get the huge
bonuses in a year but in the next year
if the bank goes out of business no one
asked them to kind of give back their
bonuses so I'm not going to defend it
I'm just going to say that it's not
unique to hedge funds now the other kind
of notion that sometimes people talk
relative to a hedge fund is this idea of
secrecy is this idea of secrecy because
it is not regulated the hedge fund
manager kind of has its choice of what
they do over here and this secrecy and
I'll put a little asterisk over here
because in order for these people to be
willing to commit their fund the hedge
fund manager has to tell them something
about what he's up to so it's up to the
hedge fund manager but some people worry
that the secrecy the secrecy that the
hedge fund has combined with the fact
that they're allowed to invest in more I
guess you could say exotic things they
don't have to and I want to be very
clear here a lot of hedge funds
even though they have this whole
structure with the 2% management fee and
the 20% and the 20% carried interest a
lot of hedge funds their actual
investments would might look very
similar to a lot of mutual funds in fact
some of them might be more conservative
than many mutual funds so it's not
necessarily the case that hedge funds
are doing crazy things over here but
some of them are and so that combination
of the secrecy and that they might be
you know speculating on this or that or
buying all sorts of crazy derivatives
contracts that makes people feel that
hey there might be something shady going
on over here and the way I think about
it is if the hedge fund is relatively
small and one hundred million dollars
would actually be small on the scale of
a hedge fund so I guess another way to
think about it if the assets that are
controlled are relatively small because
with sophisticated derivatives with 100
million dollars you can actually control
much more than 100 million dollars in
notional assets but if the notional
assets that the hedge fund controls are
relatively small then the secrecy and
kind of the you know whatever the hedge
fund might do it really just puts the
investors of the hedge fund at risk and
so it's really these people's job it
doesn't put society as a whole at risk
the time when hedge funds get dangerous
or potentially get dangerous and the
most cited example of this is long-term
capital management in the late 90s let
me write that down
LTCM I'll do a whole series of videos on
this eventually but long-term capital
management controlled so much in
notional funds now we're talking about
the hundreds of billions or even
trillions of dollars that this fund
became too big to fail too big to fail
and I think you know from the recent
financial crisis that this doesn't
happen only to hedge funds and so you
have this general notion that when any
financial institution starts starts kind
of controlling trillions of dollars or
hundreds of billions of dollars and
could start a cascade through the entire
financial system that's not a good thing
this is not a good thing this is not
good because when something is too big
to fail people don't let it fail and
that goes against everything that we
know about capitalism capitalism when
people do well let them do well but when
people fail let them fail
the thing I want to point out is that
this is not unique to hedge funds AIG
which is probably one of the main
culprits of the last of the last
financial crisis they were an insurer do
you have you know the rating agencies
they weren't too big to fail but they
helped kind of they helped kind of
validate some of these other too big to
fail actors you had all of these banks
that were too big to fail so I think the
general principle here is that the hedge
fund can be good it can be bad what's
unique about them relative to a mutual
fund is that they tend to be a little
bit more private they have they have
more support a should have more
sophisticated investors but what they do
with their money might be exactly what
the same thing as what a mutual fund
might do it might even be more
conservative than a mutual fund it might
take on it might use sophisticated
instruments to take on less risk than a
mutual fund and I think the the takeaway
or at least in my mind is any of these
things hedge funds insurance companies
banks even some corporations they become
bad when they become so big that failure
doesn't just hurt their just doesn't
just hurt their investors it hurts all
of society